what I guess they call themselves in
cells involuntary celibates when all
this stuff went down this car drove his
car into a group of people it's horrible
tragedy one of the things that you
talked about within cells is that and
this was a part of the Rome what was it
there's a New York Times piece you you
said one of the cures for this is
enforced monogamy
people decided and you know I had never
heard that term before quite honestly
and that was like what the fuck does
that mean it's a psychological term and
what it means is enforced by culture
that it is a good value monogamy yeah
because plaguing polygamous societies
tend to become ultra violent yeah and
that's been known in the anthropological
literature for a hundred years and and
certainly leftist anthropologists were
among those who discovered it like she
knew the journalist knew perfectly well
what I meant by enforcement all gonna be
she was stupid
it's a you use it as if everybody would
understand it because you're an
intellectual and because you're a
professor and it was also two minutes
out of a two-day conversation you know
it's like so if that's how she we just
glanced oh well it's so fun that was
funny in some sense because my sense is
if you want a pillory someone you should
attribute to them views that someone
somewhere has had and the implication of
that part of the New York Times article
was that I wanted to you know take
nubile young women at the point of a gun
under state enforcement and deliver them
yet useless man it's like no one has
ever believed that so Trinity sounds
like yeah it's a really the optics of
that that statement are very bad but the
question is why didn't why wasn't there
follow-up questions and if there was
follow-up questions to get you to define
what you mean by enforcement not well
there were they didn't make it into the
piece that's a real problem yeah it's a
real problem that's a real problem
because that's that that is it's so
ridiculous because inaccurate definition
of who you are one of the things I've
said continually I'm and this is on
record in multiple places it's like okay
so you're a young man mm-hmm
and all the women are rejecting you
who's got the problem
it's not all the women that's a bad road
to go down if all the women are
rejecting you it's you we both agree on
this but why is in force monogamy the
solution for people that are involuntary
celibates well it's the solution to them
it's the solution to the relationship
between men and women fundamentally is
monogamous social norm men are
unattractive if these were suggestion to
them but if these men are unattractive
to women I don't mean just physically
unattractive mean women aren't seeking
them as mates hmm they need to become
men yes they certainly do this illusion
that's the solution absolute and we both
agree on this yes what they need to do
that in this society where monogamy is
the social norm but isn't a social norm
anyway
well that was partly my point although
to the degree that we deviate from that
we tilt towards a more violent society I
was making a very minor point I don't
think they're related quite honestly I
know I don't think that involuntary
celibates I don't think that having
enforced monogamy as a part of our
cultural norm is going to help those
people
it does how's it gonna help them well
because what happens is if a polygamous
society develops which is the
alternative then a small minority of men
get all the women that's what happened
okay I could see that's the only point
which makes theory let theoretical world
where polygamous societies exist and
mass and then you do have this problem
with this a small group of man that are
fucking all the women but that's not
what we're talking and also making the
women unhappy right because the women
don't have any access to a genuine
intimate one-to-one relationship over
any long period of time which doesn't
work well MA it's the whole idea you
want that right sure if you have
children right but I still don't think
that that is why these men are
involuntary celibates and I don't think
it's the solution to that I think the
solution is that they need to become
attractive yes that is the solution I
don't think the two are related well the
only I was making a minor point the
minor point was that one of the ways
that societies around the world have
figured out that you keep young male
aggression under control is by enforcing
monogamous standards because it gives
everyone a chance in some sense that's
the only chance meaning it
clears more more women will be available
for one-on-one relationships rather than
one guy who is some you know whatever
for whatever reason what you see this
well you see this happening in
universities where women outnumber men
so the man hypothetically have more
sexual opportunity but that isn't what
happens what happens is that a small
minority of men have all the sexual
opportunity a fairly large minority of
men don't the women are on how because
they can't find a committed relationship
it's bad for most of the men and the men
who have all the sexual opportunity gets
cynical but isn't this in some ways
against your whole idea of equality of
outcome because you're you're talking
about equality of sexual outcome now if
these men have that's the dominant
basketball player that just kicks
everyone's ass this is the this this is
a guy who's succeeded at the highest
level right well there's going to be
people like that sexually there's going
to be people that are better at finding
mates and that this is what they enjoy
they enjoy having many mates enjoy being
yes but but if this is what they enjoy
if it's a man who doesn't want a family
and enjoys dating multiple women why is
that bad well the I think the
fundamental reason it's bad is because
it's bad in the long run for children
it's bad for children if he chooses to
have children fundamental issue as far
as I'm concerned right and I think it's
the answer look to give the journalist
credit that is the point she was making
you know apart from pillory me and and
and and caricature in my perspective
that was the point she was making well
first of all I'm not in favor of
unbridled hierarchies I've already said
that you know the proclivity of a
hierarchy is that they're all the spoils
go to the person at the top right and
that can destabilize the whole structure
yes so we have to have a dialogue about
how to rectify that but how did you
possibly rectify that if one man is but
like say if we've got one six foot five
beautiful man who's got a perfect body
and yet brilliant and he just wants to
date a bunch of women yeah and all the
rest of the people are
five foot one and they're fat and
they're lazy and like this guy's gonna
if this is the competition he's going to
win yep yep there's no way around this
and yet even ones decide to have
enforced monogamy where it becomes a
popular thing that women are gonna be
more drawn to him if he chooses to date
them they might decide I would rather
have him sometimes than never is that
actually what does happen but what is
wrong with that well what's wrong with
it is that it destabilized the society
and it's bad for children right you said
that yeah but that's what if they don't
want to have children but there's a lot
of people that don't want to have
children there's a lot of people that
choose to go their entire life without
having children there's men in their 30s
I'm one some of my friends have
vasectomies they don't want children hmm
so why why would that help in any way
these involuntary celibates well I think
you tilt the society so that it serves
the interests of well that's a good
question to you but you see my point
well yeah I see your point no doubt
about it
you're almost having you're almost
forcing and in an equality of outcome no
that would not was her point to him to
the degree that she had a point that was
her point now and but I but it's not who
doesn't run contrary to my opinions that
the issue of outcome has to be addressed
I already said there's needs to be a
reason for the left and the right and
then the problem with hierarchies is
they can get too steep and destabilize
everything that does happen that
particularly happens in the sexual
domain and there's plenty of
anthropological evidence for that but
you still might say well who cares
because the men who are who are winning
should be allowed to win and the women
should be allowed to choose it's right
yes except that there's the problem of
children and so society steps in on
behalf of the children and you can say
well lots of people don't want to have
children and yes and that's truer now
than it used to be although many of
those people end up having children
anyways you know the guys who sit around
all the time so that doesn't circumvent
the problem but the issue here for me
isn't the men or the women it's the
children if we're trying to set up
societies where the probability that
children will be raised in something
approximated an optimal environment is
optimized and that's going to mean
sacrifice of opportunity and choice on
the part of adults is necessary
with you but I think that what we're
talking about mirrors what we're talking
about in sports it mirrors what we're
talking about in business it's
everything else there's going to be
people that are better at all different
aspects of life there's going to be
people that are talented in terms of
like getting women to like them yes
that's true well that's why I also look
you see this right women are high
Pergamus which means they mate up in a
crew they meet across a knop dominance
hierarchies and so if you're a male
who's successful in a given hierarchy
the probability that you're gonna have
additional mating opportunities is
exceptionally high it's an unbelievably
good predictor of that that hypergamy is
a very uncomfortable discussion yes I'm
certainly there's plenty of inaudible
discussions too that's a big one though
it is the idea that it defines women's
sexual choices by the fact that they
want begger bigger better
well someone who's more more successful
and someone who's so higher on the
social ladder than what they're
accustomed to or what they have yeah
well what women do is like mate choice
is a very difficult problem so how do
you solve it well here's how women solve
it throw the man in a ring let them
compete at whatever they're competing at
assume that the man who wins is the best
man marry him yes it's a brilliant
solution
it's a market-oriented solution it's
actually the solution that appears to
have driven our evolutionary departure
from chimpanzees it's a biological
solution it's a logical solution which
cost what is the cost well the cost is
the cost is polygamy
and so we rein that in with enforced
monogamy and we do that in order to
provide stable stable circumstances for
children is polyamorous is a polyamorous
society just as unattainable as this
utopian Marxist yes yeah I think so
because it looks like this is another
point I was making that didn't get
covered in the in in the article or the
wrote about it somewhat extensively on
my blog is that society's tilt towards
monogamy across the world is human
Universal now that doesn't mean that
people don't have polygamists or
polyamorous tendencies because they
certainly do and it's certainly also the
case that one of the women ways that
women gerrymander this system is that
like the number of women children who
are in a say say you're married and you
have children with your husband but you
also have an affair so we have a child
by another man that's more common than
anyone suspected so part of the way we
way that women solve the problem that
you're just describing and I'm not
saying anything for this or against this
this is a purely factual biological
claim is they pick a monogamous marriage
and they cheat with high status guys now
you know obviously in the confines of
the marriage that's a terrible thing but
that's a very uncomfortable subject
though for women in particular
uncomfortable subject for everyone right
but it's a very uncomfortable subject
they don't like the idea that this is a
common thing that women choose a safe
man that is willing to be monogamous
with them and perhaps maybe they're
above him in a social class or in you
know sexually and then they'll cheat
with someone who's it's common but it's
not the norm right it's still the norm
not to do that the norm is fidelity
right but but there's plenty of
exception this is enforced monogamy
Coulson or monogamy is this it's like
okay so my sons getting married in in
September and so so let's say he comes
to me in the year and he says hey Dad
guess what I've had three affairs in the
last year and they've all been
successful I haven't got caught aren't
ia good guy what am I gonna say to that
no what the hell are you doing that's
not what you're supposed to be doing
that's enforced monogamy enforcement
agha meaning the
people around you try to guide them in a
way that you think is gonna yes it's
harmonious family yes it's built deep
into the cultural norms and if that
starts to destabilize then there's
trouble and that doesn't mean that it's
not prone to all the problems that you
laid out look there isn't a bigger
problem than successful reproduction it
is the big problem and all of the
solutions that we've generated for it
are full of flaws